I am 50, 67, and not on prescription dogs.
Drugs know take several supplements for prevention.
Kid, you suggest any supplements for overall health.
I want to make sure I'm not missing something that I need.
Okay, so I'm a big fan of getting your nutrients
through your food, okay?
So I know that the very term supplement
means your supplement team, your diet.
But the best way you can, you know, be healthy is to prevent disease
and to make sure you're getting happy to good diet
that you're not causing inflammation.
So I don't think that, in one sense,
I don't think that everybody just needs supplements, okay?
I don't think everybody needs to be taking supplements all the time.
So, but in other sense, I realize that it's very difficult
to get all your nutrition through your diet,
especially as we age.
Our food has less and less nutrients in it.
Even organic food has, you know,
studies down it has far less nutrients
than organic food did to your school.
So that's just the facts.
So what do you do to try to supplement your diet?
The best thing is through whole food type nutrition.
I like greens products just in a general whole food
supplement.
Most people are deficient,
a lot of people are deficient in minerals,
taking a good mineral product can be beneficial.
And I always, and I think I have a blog post on what is a good mineral
because poorly-keylated minerals are actually bad for you.
So look at our blog about different minerals
and try to how to recognize a good versus bad mineral
supplement that's on the market.
And then deal with the causes of possible morbidity
that you have.
So if I have issues with my gut,
you deal with why do you have issues that you're gut if you have
other symptoms, heart issues, cholesterol issues,
things you wanna deal with why you have those things
that address those things.
So I like to get specific and I like to do testing.
So, but just from a general standpoint,
maybe taking a whole food nutrition
like a whole food greens first type supplement
would be the first thing to start with.
But again, I'm cautious to even recommend that
because it first has different food sensitivities.
Sometimes you can't be on that thing.
So, but that would be the most general answer
I could give you with that.